اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العناوين
الصليب الاحمر يحذر من كارثه انسانيه على
الحدود السودانيه التشاديه والقصف المدفعي
يهدد وقفه اطلاق النار
يدعو لتوسيع الانتاج العسكري لامداد كيف
بالاسلحه يحذر من اقتراب سيناريو الحرب
النوويه
رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي يحذر من
تطورات سلبيه تجاه ايران قد تستدعي عملا
عسكريا اسرائيليا
والجمهوريون يشترطون خفضا كبيرا في
النفقات للموافقه على رفع سقف الدين وسط
تحذيرات من نفاد الاموال
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه
خروقات واطلاق نار وقصف مدفعي جميعها
احداث تهدد الهدنه في السودان بعد ساعات
من دخولها حيز التنفيذ فقد تحدثت وسائل
اعلام عن سماع اصوات مواجهات وغارات جويه
جنوب العاصمه وفي الضواحي الشماليه
الشرقيه بالاضافه الى وقوع الشبكات في
شارع الغابه وسط الخرطوم هذا واعلنت وزاره
الصحه ان القوات الدعم السريع تتمركز في
28 مستشفى وست مؤسسات صحيه بما حذرت
اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر من خطر وقوع
كارثه تهدد سلامه اللاجئين السودانيين في
تشاد مع اقتراب موسم الامطار في اواخر شهر
يونيو القادم
مجلس الوزراء السعودي رحب من جهته بتوقيع
طرفي النزاع بالسودان على اتفاق وقف اطلاق
النار قصير الامل كما اعرب مجلس الوزراء
السعودي برئاسه الملك سلمان عن امله في ان
تركز المحادثات السودانيه على وقف دائم
للاعمال العدائيه وتفعيل العمليه السياسيه
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني بلانكن كان
قد دعا الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
الى الالتزام بالهدنه المتفق عليها وقال
بلنكن ان العنف الذي ارتكبه طرفا الصراع
ماساوي ومدمر وبلا معنى مشيرا الى ان
العالم يصر على حل تفاوض
ان العنف الذي ارتكبته القوات المسلحه
السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع الشهر
الماضي كان ماساويا وبلا معنى ومدمرا لقد
اتحد العالم كله في الدعوه لانهاء هذا
الصراع والاصرار على حل تفوضي ان الاتفاق
بين القوات المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم
السريع على هذه الاتفاقيه لوقف اطلاق
النار لمده قصيره كان نتيجه الدبلوماسيه
المكثفه وشراك الوثيقه بين المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والولايات المتحده
وقد هدد بلنكن بمحاسبه المنتهكين وفرض
عقوبات عليهم محملا الجيش والدعم السريع
مسؤوليه تطبيق اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار في
البلاد
اذا انتهك وقف اطلاق النار سنعرف وسنحاسب
المخالفين من خلال عقوبات نفرضها ووسائل
اخرى متاحه لنا لقد ظللنا الصعوبات
للتواصل الى وقف اطلاق النار هذا لكن
مسؤوليه تنفيذه تقع على عاتق القوات
المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع ان
الحل الدائم للصراع يتطلب اكثر من ذلك
بكثير اريد ان اوضح ان المدنيين في
السودان يجب ان يكونوا من يحددون مسار
السودان للمضي قدما
اذهب الى الخرطوم لمزيد من المتابعه الان
ينضم اليهم هناك الصحفي عمار ابو عمار
اهلا وسهلا بك جديد المشهد الميداني وهل
يبدو لك ان ثمه التزاما ولو جزئيا بوقت
اطلاق النار ام لا الامور حتى الساعه لا
تبشر بالخير صح التعبير
اهلا بك يا طالب نعم هنا في شرق العاصمه
الخرطوم يعني يمكن ان نقول بان تم التزام
بالهدنه وانها ما زالت محافظه على قوتها
في هذه المنطقه خاصه مناطق شرق العاصمه
الخرطوم ومناطق شرق النيل وعدد كذلك من
المناطق المحيطه بمحيط القياده العامه
للجيش ومطار الخرطوم باعتبار ان هذه
المناطق الاستراتيجيه كانت دائما ما يتم
فيها خرق الهدن السابقه بفعل الاشتباكات
التي تدور فيها في هذه المنطقه ومنذ
الساعات الاولى لاعلان دخول الهدنه حيز
التنفيذ لم تجري اشتباكات عسكريه ولم
نستمع الى صوت تحليق الطيران ولم نرى
الطائرات الحربيه التي كانت تحلق بكثافه
ولا حتى الطائرات الاستكشاف والاستطلاع
يمكن ان نقول وبشكل كبير بان الهدنه هنا
ما زالت محافظه
عمار هل تسمعني يبدو ان فقدنا الاتصال مع
عمار انت على الهواء عمار تفضل
نعم طالب كنت اقول بان هنا المنطقه الشرق
العاصمه الخرطوم وعدد من المناطق المحيطه
بمطار الخرطوم الدولي وكذلك القياده
العامه للجيش هذه المناطق ما زالت محافظه
على تماسكها وما زالت الهدنه فيها قائمه
باقي المناطق الاخرى عمار يعني مناطق اخرى
لم يتم فيها التزام كامل بوقف اطلاق النار
نعم كانت هنالك معلومات وردت بان هنالك
اشتباكات في شارع الغابه في وسط العاصمه
الخرطوم وهذه الاشتباكات ايضا كذلك بحسب
المصادر الميدانيه التي اشرت انها لم تكن
اشتباكات بالاسلحه الثقيله او حتى كان
هنالك قصف جوي بالطيران او حتى في مناطق
في ام درمان كانت هنالك ربما عمليات
احتكاك وتمشيط بين عدد من القوات في الارض
منطقه السوق العربي ايضا كذلك هي منطقه
مفصليه وتدور فيها عدد من المعارك لم تشهد
اشتباكات عنيفه هذه الاشتباكات هي منوشات
في عدد المناطق خاصه ايضا مدينه بحر
اللافت في هذه النقاط الكثيره جدا طالب
بان الطيران الحربي حينما يكون في المعركه
تكون هنالك المدفعيه الثقيله وتكون هناك
المضادات الارضيه ذات الكثافه العاليه
المنتشره في عدد كبير جدا من المناطق خاصه
منطقه شرق النيل وشرق العاصمه الخرطوم
ووسط العاصمه وعدد كبير ايضا كذلك من
الاحياء السكنيه في مدينه بحري او حتى في
ام درمان القديمه
ايضا طالب في هذه المرات ان هذه الهدنه
تلقت وبشكل واضح جرعه ربما التمهيديه
كبيره جدا فيما يخص الالتزام بها هنالك من
تحدثوا بانهم استطاعوا الحركه في مناطق لم
يكونوا يستطيعوا فيها الحركه من قبل
واستطاع الدخول لعدد من منازلهم ومن ثم
اخذ عدد من الاحتياجات والحاجات الضروريه
كالاوراق الثبوتيه وعددين ايضا كذلك من
الامتعه هنالك من تحدثوا بصعوبه الوصول
باعتبار انها لم يكن هنالك اشارات الى
مرور الطرق او حتى يعني المرور عبر الجسور
هنالك اشارات ايضا كذلك لان عدد من
الاسواق خاصه في مدينه شمال بدات تعمل
بشكل تدريجي وحتى خطوط المواصلات بدات
تتحرك
هل يعني هل من معلومات اضافيه عن موضوع
تدفق المساعدات الانسانيه تحديدا الطبيه
الغذائيه وغيرها قيل انه يعني خطوط
الامداد هي مؤ منه من قبل الطرفين الى اي
مدى هذا الكلام صحيح
نعم هذا من خلال بنود الاتفاق اعلان جده
الاخير ولكن حتى الان لم يتم تحديد سير
هذه الخطوط خطوط الامداد الانسانيه كيف
ستتحرك في مناطق الاشتباكات او حتى في
المناطق التي يسيطر عليها الجيش او في
الجانب الاخر قوات الدعم السريع لم توضح
بشكل واضح خريطه ميدانيه تتحرك فيها
المساعدات الانسانيه كان هنالك حديث عن
خروج من المستشفيات والمنازل ايضا كذلك
وقف للطيران والقصف الجوي وايضا المضادات
الارضيه وكل اشكال العدائيات ما بين
الجانبين ولكن حتى الان ينتظر الناس وبشكل
واسع وكبير كيف تتحرك هذه المساعدات
الانسانيه خاصه وان هنالك رجال كانت قد
تكونت وتم التسميه هل هنالك تفاؤل من قبل
الطرفين
بان هذه لاطلاق النار سيصمد ام لا مع مرور
الوقت
سيسقط هذا الاتفاق
طالما ان الطرفين وقع على الاتفاق يبدو ان
هنالك فصحى لهذا المجال بشكل واضح وكبير
باعتبار ان ايضا المعارك الحربيه يمكن ان
تنخفض ويمكن ان ترتفع مره وتعود مره اخرى
وتم تحديد سقف زمني سبعه ايام يمكن من
خلال هذه سبعه ايام ايضا كذلك للجانب
العسكري ان يعيد عدد من الترتيبات داخل
البيئه العسكريه وداخل القواعد العسكريه
ومن ثم يتيح ايضا كذلك فسحه ومجال
للمواطنين لكثير جدا من الاعمال الانسانيه
ساكتفي بهذا القدر من الخرطوم عمار ابو
شيبه شكرا جزيلا لك عمار على كل هذه
المتابعه
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه التصدي
لمجموعه قوميين اوكرانيين توغلوا في
مقاطعه بيلجرود الحدوديه وقال المتحدث
باسم الوزاره ايغور كناشينكوف ان القوات
الجويه والمدفعيه شاركت في جهود التصدي
للمجموعه المسلحه وقتل سبعين منه مشيرا
الى فراري بقاياها الى داخل اوكرانيا
الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان قواتها ما تزال
تسيطر على مواقع في جنوب غرب ضخمه
وقالت نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان
وتيره القتال داخل بخمه انخفضت بشكل كبير
بينما تقوم القوات الروسيه بتمشيط المناطق
التي سيطرت عليها
[موسيقى]
الى دوناتسك لمزيد من المتابعين
المشهد الميداني رائد وما الذي جرى تحديدا
في بيلجورود والى اي مدى هذه المساله شكلت
خطرا كبيرا على الروس
مساء الخير طالب يعني بالفعل المجتمع
الروسي والشارع الروسي امتعظ كثيرا من
تسلل اعداد كبيره بمركباتهم العسكريه من
القوات الاوكرانيه الى الاراضي الروسيه
والحديث عن انسحاب حرس الحدود من تلك
المنطقه وتواجد القوات الاوكرانيه في نقاط
التفتيش الروسيه على الحدود لكن يعني
تعاملت جيش الروسي مع هذه المجموعات
الارهابيه بعد تحصنها في ابنيه سكنيه حسب
المصادر من هناك وقتل سبعين منهم كما
اسلفت طالب وفرار بعض منهم واسر ايضا بعض
من المقاتلين هناك كانت مجموعات اضافيه
وصلت الى الحدود من اجل تعزيز هذا الهجوم
الارهابي كما وصفته موسكو لكن يعني سلاح
الجو الروسي تعامل مع هذه المجموعات
ونحاها حسب المصدر العسكري الروسي بالفعل
العمليات العسكريه الروسيه في ضواحي خاركب
ايا المتاخمه لم تتوقف بالقصد بالمدفعيه
وبراجمات الصواريخ هناك عمليات عسكريه
كبيره لكن حتى الكريملين كان ممتعض وعبر
عن قلقه من دخول مجموعات ارهابيه الى
الاراضي الروسيه ووعد بان لا تتكرر هذه
المسائل من حيث التحصينات الاضافيه التي
ستمتد على الحدود الروسيه الاوكرانيه
المشهد هنا ايضا في المقاطعات الانفصاليه
نعم طالب نعم رائد بالنسبه الى فقط لكي لا
تفوت هذه النقطه يعني كيف ما زالت تصر على
انه ما زال لدي لدى القوات الاوكرانيه
مواقع في بخموت انت اقرب الى المشهد منا
هنا هل فعلا ما زال القوات الاوكرانيه
مواقع جنوب غرب ضخمه ام لا يعني هذا
الكلام غير صحيح القوات الروسيه احكمت
السيطره تماما ومشطت المدينه
التصريحات الاوكرانيه صحيحه والتصريحات
الروسيه صحيحه طالب حيث وصلت قوات فاجنر
الى الحدود الاداريه للمدينه وسيطرت على
جميع نقاط المدينه ومراكزها وما زالت
القوات الاوكرانيه على اطراف هذه الحدود
ولديها اسلحه طويله المدى لديها مقاتلين
لديها حشود ايضا كما يقولون في الناحيه
الغربيه الجنوبيه وحتى في الناحيه
الشماليه وينفذون عمليات اقتحام وهجمات
يقول جانب الروسي بانه يصدها للاشاره فقط
بان قوات فاجنر انهت عملياتها وتستعد خلال
يومين للانسحاب في الخامس والعشرين بعد غد
وتسليم الجيش الروسي الذي هو متواجد على
الارض الان وهو الذي يصد هذه الهجمات
ويقاتل ضد القوات الاوكرانيه التي تحاول
العوده الى عمق مدينه باقمه القوات
الاوكرانيه متواجد حاضره فعلا لكن على
الحدود الجنوبيه الغربيه والشماليه من
مدينه باخموت اي بما معنى انهم يطوقون
نوعا ما المقاتلين الروس المتواجدين داخل
المدينه لكن اليوم زعيم الانفصاليين او
القائم باعمال الرئاسه هنا
فينيس بوشيلين كاشاره منه تواجد في مدينه
باخموت واظهر خلفه والبنايات الشاهقه في
اخر المدينه وتجول في المدينه ليقول اننا
مسيطرون على المدينه باكملها ايضا الرئيس
زيلينسكي الرئيس الاوكراني تواجد في مدينه
مارينكا المتاخمه كاشاره منه لعدم التقدم
الروسي الى المناطق حيث روسيا تقول الجيش
الروسي يؤكد انه يتقدم ولو بامتار بعده
مئات من الامطار يوميا في المحور الاخير
من مدينه مارينكا لكن زياره الرئيس تؤكد
صمود القوات الاوكرانيه في هذا المحور لكن
المحور الاهم وبعجال افديك هناك حشودات
كبيره في مدينه
المتاخمه لمار وايضا باخ مطوه برمايزكا
هناك
القوات الاوكرانيه تحشد وتقصف المدن
المجاوره مدينه ياسينافاتا هناك اعداد من
الجرحى يعني اصابات في يعني دمار للبناء
التحتيه وبعض الابنيه السكنيه المعارك
مستعره في كل المحاور وليس في باقمه وحدها
باختصار
العربي رائد الاكبر شكرا جزيلا لك رائد
على كل هذه المتابعه
هذا واكد الامير العام لحلف الناتج ضروره
زياده الدول الاعضاء لانتاجها العسكري
لامداد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه والذخيره وقال
في تصريحات صحفيه ان تدريب الطيارين
الاوكران على استخدام مقاتلات اف 16 لا
يجعلوا من الحلف طرفا في الصراع وشدد
الامين العام لحلف الناتو على ان اوكرانيا
لديها الحق في الدفاع عن النفس مشيرا لان
الحلف يساعدها على التمسك بهذا الحق
المتحدث باسم الكريم
قال من جهته ان الوضع في اوكرانيا يتجه
بوضوح نحو التصعيد بعد قرار تزويد الجيش
الاوكراني بطائرات
المخاطر واضحا ليس لنا ان نحكم على
التوقيت ولكن من الواضح ان هذا الوضع
يستمر في نمط تصاعدي مع توفير انواع
مختلفه من الاسلحه اكثر تقدما من الواضح
انه تم اتخاذ القرار باضافه طائرات ولكن
كجميع انواع الاسلحه الاخرى فهي غير قادره
على تغيير الوضع بشكل جذري على الجبهه
ربما هذا كل ما يمكن قوله هنا نواجه نفس
المواقف مره بعد اخرى اصبح الدول الغرب
منخبطه بشكل متزايد في هذا الصراع
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي ديمتري
متفيدف قال من جهته ان احتمال حدوث كارثه
نوويه يعتمد بشكل مباشر على نوع الاسلحه
المقدمه الى كيف واعتبر انه كلما زاد عدد
الاسلحه التي يتم توفيرها الكياف فان
العالم في وضع اكثر خطوره وكلما كانت هذه
الاسلحه اكثر دمارا زاد احتمال تحقيق
سيناريو ما يسمى
بنهايه العالم النوويه
من بروكسل ينضم اليه لمزيد من المتابعه
مراسل العربي نور الدين نور قبل ان اسالك
عن اي رد فعل اوروبي على كلام السيد
بدايه هل تمت قرار اوروبي واضح وجامع الان
بتدريب الطيارين الاوكراني على اف 16
وبامداد كييف ام لا ما زالت بعض الدول
الاوروبيه معترضه على ذلك
الى حد ما نعم طالب لان عدد من الدول
الاوروبيه بدات فعلا حسب كلامي جوزيف
بوريل في تدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين لكن
الدول الاوروبيه كافه لا تمتلك طائرات
ومقاتلات اف 16 وانما عدد من هذه الدول
مثل بريطانيا خارج الاتحاد الاوروبي ولكن
الدنمارك هولندا بلجيكا فرنسا على سبيل
المثال لا تمتلك طائرات مقاتلات اف 16
وانما الرئيس ماكرون اعلن ان بلاده ستدرب
الطيارين الاوكرانيين بالاكيد ان
الاوكرانيين عندما يتدربون في فرنسا فمعنى
ذلك انهم سيتدربون على طائرات الميراج
الفيلم ولكن فرنسا لم تعلن عن تزويد
اوكرانيا بطائرات بمقاتلات الان هذه
المرحله الاولى في انتظار ان بعد اشهر
يمضج الموقوف وتتحدد الاعداد والمقاتلات
طالما ان الولايات المتحده قد منحت الضوء
الاخضر لشركائها دول حلف ال كل لديها هذه
المقاتلات لكن لا نعلم الان مدى العدد او
متى ولكن الاقرب هو ان يكون من نهايه
الصيف الى بدايه الخريف المقبل من هنا الى
ذلك الحين ستكون المعركه قد تغيرت
طيب نور السيد اليوم يعني في كلام واضح
وصريح موقف له انه امداد كيف بهذا النوع
من الاسلحه اي الاف 16 وتدريب الطيارين
يعني ان المواجهه باتت مباشره بين الدول
الغربيه وبين موسكو وهذا قد يجر الى نهايه
العالم النوويه هل تاخذ اوروبا او الدول
الاوروبيه الاتحاد الاوروبي هذه التصريحات
على محمل الجد ام لا تعتبرها تكرار لمواقف
سابقه
سمعها الاتحاد من السيد
يعني التهديد بالسلاح نووي هو دائما كلام
يؤخذ على محمل الجد ولكن هذه التصريحات
المتكرره من الجانب الروسي وخاصه من جانب
السيد
جعلت الامر كانه نوع من التهديد الروتيني
الذي يصدر عن موسكو من كل ما تقدم الاتحاد
الاوروبي او الناتوبي من خطوات عسكريه
سواء كان في اتجاه التوسع او في اتجاه
التزويد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه ولكن رد عليه
بطريقه غير مباشره جوزيف بوريل عندما انهى
اجتماعات وزراء الدفاع فقال بما ان
الاسابيع المقبله ستكون حاسمه بالنسبه
لحرب اوكرانيا هو يستند في ذلك الى معطيات
ملموسه قدمها اليوم وكشف عنها لاول مره من
ان الاتحاد ان الدول الاوروبيه قدمت 200
او زودت اوكرانيا بمئتين وعشرين الف قذيفه
حتى الان وان العمل الجاري لتزويدها
بمئات الالاف حتى تصل الى مليون قذيفه هذا
العام ان الدول الاوروبيه زودت اوكرانيا
في المرحله الم
1300 صاروخ ان الاتحاد الاوروبي درب الى
حد الان تحت مسؤولياته يعني اتحاد
الاوروبي ولكن الدول الاعضاء هي التي تقوم
بذلك درب الى حد الان 20 الف مقاتل
اوكراني والخطه
يعني تهدف الى تدريب 30 الف هذا بعد ما
قاله الامين العام من ان في الشهر الماضي
زودت كل من بريطانيا المانيا فرنسا
الولايات المتحده اوكرانيا
ايضا
وصواريخ طويله المدى التي قدمتها بريطانيا
في الاسبوع الماضي صاروخ
في انتظار ربما تكتمل المنظومه بطائرات
الاف سته عشر
ساكتفي بهذا القدر من بروكس المراسل
العربي نور الدين الفريدي شكرا جزيلا لك
نور على كل هذه المتابعه
نشاط الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
عمران
خانيه محاسبه في قضيه فساد
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه اكد رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي
هرتشي ان بلاده وفي لحظه ما قد تضطر
للتدخل بسبب التطورات الحاصله في ملف
ايران النووي الامر الذي قد يستدعي عملا
اسرائيليا على حد تعبيره خاصه وان ايران
قطعت شوطا كبيرا في تخصيب اليورانيوم وذلك
في خضم تحذيرات تل ابيب من نشاط طهران
المزعزع للاستقرار الاقليمي والدولي حسب
قوله
قررت محكمه الاسلام اباء تمديد كفاله رئيس
الوزراء الباكستاني السابق عمران خان ضد
الاعتقال في عده قضايا تتعلق بالارهاب ومن
المقرر ايضا ان يمثل عمران خان وزوجته
امام فرعي لمكتب المحاسبه الوطني في
العاصمه اسلام اباد حيث يواجهان تهمه فساد
تتعلق بما يعرف بقضيه وقف القادر والتي
يتهم فيها بالاستحواذ على اراض واموال
بقيمه 190 مليون جنيه استرليني بطريقه غير
شرعيه عمران خان نفى كافه التهم ضدها
ووصفها بالمسيسه
لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذا الموضوع مراسل
العربي عبد الرحمن المزيني عبد الرحمن
اهلا وسهلا بالتمديد كفاله عمران خان يحل
الازمه من جذورها وينزع صاعق التفجير من
الشارع ام لا الامور ذاهبه الى مزيد من
التصعيد
يبدو ان السلطات الباكستانيه طالب
تنتهج سياسه النفس الطويل مع رئيس الوزراء
السابق عمران خان في كل مره يتم فيها منح
رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان كفالات
مؤقته ضد الاعتقان يزداد فيها اعداد
المنشقين عن حزبه لا سيما من الصفوف
الدنيا وبدانا نرى الان بعض قاده ونواب
حزبه من الصفوف الصف قيادات الصف الثاني
وهناك ايضا الحديث عن بعض قيادات الصف
الاول في حزبه مع ان ابرزهم اليوم وزيره
حقوق الانسان في الحكومه السابقه التي
اعلنت استقالتها من الحزب وترك العمل
السياسي كلما طالت الازمه كلما انعكس ذلك
سلبا على رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان
وعلى حزبه وعلى تماسك حزبه ناتي على
السياق
الحديث عن
القضايا التي مثل امامها عمران خان
المحكمه محكمه محكمه تعنى بقضايا الارهاب
مددت الكفالات الممنوحه لعمران خان في
ثماني قضايا تتعلق باعمال الشغب والفوضى
التي رافقت مثوله امام المجمع القضائي في
وقت سابق في العاصمه اسلام اباد وليس ولا
يتعلق باليوم الذي تم اعتقاله فيه اليوم
الذي تم اعتقاله فيه لا تزال الكفاله
ساريه اليوم
القضايا الثمانيه التي رفعت ضده ضمن بنود
الارهاب المحكمه قررت تنفيذها حتى فيما
يتعلق في بنود الارهاب عبد الرحمن طب
بالنسبه
بس ولكن بالنسبه الى قضيه ما يعرف بوقف
القادر هل من ضمانات بان عمران خان لن
يعتقل بسبب هذه القضيه مع العلم ان عمران
خان يقول ان هذه المساله مسيسه بالدرجه
الاولى
[موسيقى]
بخصوص زوجته زوجته زوجته عمران بشرى بيبي
حصلت على كفاله من اعتقال على خلفيه
القضيه لانه لم يسبق ان تم استدعائها الى
مكتب المحاسبه الوطني اما بخصوص عمران خان
فقد مثل اليوم
واستمرت استمر
الاستجواب والتحقيق معه لاكثر من اربع
ساعات غادر بعدها الى مدينه لاهور حيث
منزله هناك يقيم في مدينه لاغور لكن هذا
لا يعني انتهاء ملف القضيه كان هناك سلسله
من الاسئله التي طرحها المحققون كما طلبوا
من رئيس الوزراء السابق تقديم كافه
المستندات
الاوراق السعوديه المتعلقه بما يعرف بوقف
القادر حيث يتهم في بالاستحواذ على اموال
واراضي
تناهز 190 مليون جنيه استرليني من المتوقع
ان يتم استدعائ وربما في تاريخ اخر حول
هذه القضيه لكن اود الاشاره هنا الى ان
عمران خان لا يواجه فقط هذه القضيه
فيما يتعلق بقضاء الفساد هناك ما يعرف
بصندوق الهدايا او الهدايا التي
تتهمه فيها السلطات بالاستحواذ على هدايا
مخصصه للدوله بطريقه غير شرعيه اضافه الى
قضايا اخرى عمران خان اثناء امتثاله اليوم
امام القضاء قال انه يواجه نحو 150 قضيه
ما بين قضيه وبلاغ وهو لا يستطيع ان يؤتي
او
يحضر امام كافه هذه المحاكمات التي امام
هذه القضايا الموجهه ضدها والتي يصفها
بالمسيسه
هي اضافه الى حديث انه هناك تهديدات على
حياته الى سيما هو لا سيما وانه قد سبق ان
تعرض لمحاوله اغتيال سابقه ساكتفي بهذا
القدر من اسلام اباد مراسل العربي عبد
الرحمن المزيني شكرا جزيلا لك عبد الرحمن
على كل هذه المتابعه
نشرت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز تحقيقا صحافيا
عن المئات من المهاجرين الافغان الذين
يحاولون الوصول الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه عبر غابات امريكا الجنوبيه
ويقول التحقيق الذي التقى بعدم كبير من
هؤلاء المهاجرين ان الانسحاب الامريكي من
كابول كان بدايه رحله طويله وخطيره للالاف
للبحث عن الامام
السيد طيبه من مسؤوله في الحكومه
الافغانيه تحارب العنف ضد المراه وتحمي
النساء الى مهاجره هائمه على وجهها في
ادغال امريكا الجنوبيه تحقيق النشره صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز عن مئات المهاجرين الافغان
الذين يحاولون الوصول الى الولايات
المتحده بعد ان تركوا عرضه للقتل والتهديد
في افغانستان
وزوجها وطفلها ومثلها
3600 افغاني ممن عملوا ناشطين حقوقيين او
مسؤولين حكوميين ابان الوجود الاميركي في
افغانستان باعوا بيوتهم واملاكهم وفروا من
تهديدات انتقاميه قطعوا
عشره دوله ناموا في الادغال مع الافاعي
والنمل الاحمر ليصلوا الى منطقه دارين بين
بنما وكولومبيا بهدف التسلل الى الولايات
المتحده او كندا برفقه الاف المهاجرين من
جنسيات اخرى
في الايام الاخيره ربما هناك تراجع طفيف
في عدد الاشخاص الذين يعبرون هذا المكان
لكن الاسباب التي تدفع هؤلاء الناس للتسلل
وحمل عائلاتهم وكل حياتهم ومحاوله اعاده
بنائها في مكان اخر ما زالت موجوده ولم
تتغير ما زال هناك عنف واضطهاد واخرون
يبحثون عن حياه افضل وهذه الامور بحاجه
لمعالجه جذريه
وفق نيويورك تايمز تفتخر اداره بايدن التي
خرجت من كابول في اغسطس من عام 2021 بنقل
نحو 88 الف افغاني الى اماكن امنه لكنها
ابقت خلفها عشرات الالاف من من عملوا مع
الحكومه والمنظمات الامريكيه خلال 20 عاما
يتعرضون يوميا لخطر الانتقام او القتل
استانفت اغلب المخابز في تونس نشاطها
العادي بعد تزودها بماده الدقيق الابيض
وفق ما اكده مسؤول بنقابه القطاع جاء ذلك
بعد ساعات قليله من دعوه الرئيس قيس سعيد
الى التشريع بحسم مساله الحبوب مشددا على
وجود شبكات اجراميه تسعى الى تجويع الشعب
وكان عدد من المخابز قد توقف عن تصنيع
الخبز بسبب الاضطراب المسجل في التزود
بالدقيق
خير ربي موجود السميد موجود
الفرينه موجوده
والمافيا مش مخليتها العباده دي معناها
تخدم على راحتها يحبو يحطوا الاعصاب
بالعزاء في البلاد
الله اعلم
احنا عملناه خارج الخبز الصبيح فمتني في
عشره خبزات وفي عشرين
خبز موجود
يرفض دعوه رفعها مساهمون على ايلون ماسك
بسبب استحواذه على تويتر
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه استانف الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
محادثاته مع الجمهوريين في الكونغرس بهدف
التوصل الى اتفاق يجنب الولايات المتحده
التخلف عن سداد مستحقات ديونها وسط
تحذيراته وزاره الخزانه من نفاد اموال
الخزينه العامه بعد الاول من حزيران يونيو
تداعيات التخلف عن السداد ستكون كارثيه
ويحث الجمهوريون على الموافقه على زياده
نظيفه قد يقولون في سقف الاقتراض العام
قبل الاول من الشهر المقبل لكن الجمهوريين
يشترطون ان يوافق بايدن على خفض كبير في
نفقات الميزانيه مقابل موافقتهم على رفع
سقف الدين العام
اذا اعزائي المشاهدين اسابيع من المفاوضات
وصلت الى طريق مسدود حتى الان بين الطرفين
فما الذي يعيق صفقه سقف الديون نقطه
الخلاف الاولى هي وضع حد اقصى لمقدار
الانفاق الحكومي للميزانيات الفيدراليه
المستقبليه كما اقترح الجمهوريون
الجمهوريون ايضا يرغبون بوقف مساعدات
قصائم الطعام والمساعدات الماليه والطبيه
الخلاف الثالث هو الاموال غير المنفقه
التي كانت مخصصه لدعم الشركات وحكومات
الولايات التي تتعامل مع جائحه كورونا من
قبل وزاره الخزانه
نقطه خلاف اخرى هي تصاريح الطاقه وما اذا
كان يجب تسهيل منح الحكومه الفيدراليه
تصاريح للشركات الخاصه لمشاريع تطوير
الطاقه مثل التنقيب عن النفط وبناء محطات
الطاقه
ويتخوف الكثيرون من تعذر الولايات المتحده
عن سداد ديونها البالغه اكثر من 31
تريليون دولار ما قد يؤدي الى ازمه وفوضى
عالميه الا ان محللين يقولون ان تاثير هو
ان الاقتصاد العالمي سيتباطى كما ان
معدلات الرهن العقاري قد ترتفع بالاضافه
الى السلع المهمه كالنفط
والقمح
[موسيقى]
معي من باريس لمزيد من المتابعه لهذا
الموضوع الباحث الاقتصادي الدكتور دانيال
ملحم دكتور دانيال اهلا وسهلا بك هذا
السيناريو الان هل يمكن القول
كما يقال بالفرنسيه بمعنى انه مناورات
محسوبه السقوف
ولكن قبل الاول من حزيران في اتفاق ام لا
هذه المره الامور مختلفه تماما مع ما
يعنيه ذلك ان عدم الاتفاق سيؤثر ليس فقط
على الاقتصاد الامريكي بل على الاقتصاد
العالمي ككل
تحيه لك سيدي والمشاهدين الكرام صحيح ما
ذكرت ان الرقصه اليوم تختلف كليا عن رقصه
2011 او الرقصه الذي حدثت او الرقصات التي
حدثت في الفترات الماضيه اليوم هي تاتي او
الرقص على الحافه او على حافه الهاويه من
قبل الجمهوريه والديمقراطيين تاتي في ظروف
حساسه جدا هناك تضخم مرتفع هناك سياسه
نقديه في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بدات
تصل الى ذروتها هناك اضطرابات ماليه
اضطرابات في القطاع المصرفي الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هناك الكثير من
المشكلات وتاتي اليوم نتكلم عن تخلف
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه عن عن السداد
وهذا عمليا سوف يؤدي الى زياده الضغوطات
على الاسواق زياده الضغوطات على الاقتصاد
الامريكي وخاصه نحن نتكلم اليوم ان 13
مليار عفوا 13 تريليون دولار هي مملوكه هو
دين خارجي الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وهذا هذا هذا هو هذا المبلغ يزيد خمسه
اضعاف عما كان عليه في السابق لذلك الوضع
مختلف كليا ولكن اليوم لا هذا السيناريو
والتخلف عن السداد هو السيناريو الاقل
حدوثا في خلال الفتره المقبله لان هناك
الكثير من السنيورهات
الاكثر حدوثا والكثير من الحلول الموجوده
في جامعه بايدن او في جعبه الفيدرالي ابرز
هذه الحلول برايك الحلول الوسط سواء من
قبل الجمهوريين او من قبل الديمقراطيين
برايك يعني اكيد ما حدا حيروح على كسر عظم
يعني كما او على الاقل هذا المستبعد ولكن
يعني اين يمكن ان يتنازل الرئيس بايدن
والديمقراطيون واين يمكن ان يتنازل
الجمهوريون دكتور دانيال وفق متابعته
الصحيحه اليوم اليوم المشكله هناك الكثير
من الذكاء ذكرتها حضرتك قبل قليل ولكن
هناك نقطتين اعتقد انه هن لب المشكله
الجمهوريين هو يطلبون صحيح في قطاع النفط
ولكن في قطاع الادويه يطلبون الكثير من
النقاط واكثر من ذلك هي عمليا السياسات
الضريبيه اليوم بايدن هو يكون سوف يزيد
يخفض الانفاق هو مقترحه بتخفيض الانفاق
بحدود الاتريون دولار وتخفيض العجز بثلاثه
تريليون دولار وهذه عمليا هي سياسه ضريبيه
وهذه الديمقراطيين هي عمليه يلجاوها هنا
نقطه الخلافه لان الجمهوريه هي ضد هذه
النقطه بالذات هناك احتمال اليوم
الفيدرالي لسيناريو ان يتم اتفاق داخل
الكونغرس
وفي حال لم يتم هناك هذا الاتفاق سوف يكون
في اجابه بايدن يا اما اللجوء الى الماده
14 من الدستور لسد الدين العام ولكن هناك
مشكله ان يلجا الديمقراطي ان يلجا
الجمهوريون الى المحكمه العليا ويوقف هذا
هذا لانه نحن نتكلم في العشره ايام
الاخيره هناك ايضا يمكن ان يلجا بايضا الى
استخدام او وزاره
دعوات حكوميه بريطانيه لمعالجه ارتفاع
معدلات الهجره الى بريطانيا عن طريقه فرض
اجراءات اكثر حزما على الطلاب والعمال
الاجانب الذين ياتون مع عائلاتهم
وبالارقام فقد بلغ عدد التاشيرات التي
منحت لافراد عائلات الطلاب 22% فيما تضاعف
عدد تاشيرات العمال الاجانب وعائلاتهم
ثلاث مرات تقريبا منذ العام 2019
وهناك حوالي 700 الف شخص دخلوا الى
بريطانيا العام الماضي اكثر ممن غادروها
الجامعات من جياتها تعترض على هذه القيود
لاعتمادها على اموال الطلاب الاجانب في ظل
عدم حصول هذه الجامعات على اموال من
الحكومه
رفض قاضن دعوه جماعيه تتهم الرئيس
التنفيذي لتويتر ايلون ماسك بخداع
المساهمين في الشركه عده مرات خلال العام
الماضي اثناء استحواذه على منصه التواصل
الاجتماعي مقابل اربعه واربعين مليار
دولار
وقال قاضي المحكمه الجزائيه الامريكيه في
سان فرانسيسكو ان مقيمه دعوه بالنيابه عن
مجموعه من المساهمين لا يملك الصفه
القانونيه لرفع هذه الدعوه لانه طعن في
اخطاء مرتبطه باستحواذ ماسك على الشركه
وليس في نزاهه عمليه الاستحواذ نفسها
الى شان اخر فقد اثبت المتسلق النيبالي
كاميريتا شربه ان الانسان باستطاعته ان
يتفوق حتى على نفسه حيث تمكن هذا الرجل
الخمسينيه الملقب برجل ايفرست من تحطيم
رقم القياسي للمره الثامنه والعشرين
معتليا قمه سطح العالم
مرتين خلال اسبوع واحد
[موسيقى]
خيمت صحابه من الرماد فوق البلدات المحيطه
بمدينه اتلاكسيكو في المكسيك بسبب الفيضان
البركاني ما سبب صعوبه في الرؤيه وتساقط
للرماد وبالتالي غرق المدينه في نوع من
الضباب البركاني نتابع
اقامت الملكه رانيا العبد الله عقيله
العاهل الاردنيه حفله حناء في مضارب بني
هاشم بالعاصمه الاردنيه عمان بمناسبه قرب
زفاف ولي العهد الامير حسين بن عبد الله
الثاني والانسه رجوى ال سيف المقرر في
الاول من يونيو المقبل وشاركت في الحفل
عدد من اميرات العائله الملكيه وسيدات
حضرنا من مختلف محافظات البلاد وقد تخلل
الحفل رسم بالحناء وزفه العروس واغاني
واهازيج تراثيه وشعبيه اردنيه وسعوديه
رفضت المحكمه العليا البريطانيه قطعنا
الذي تقدم به محمد الامير هاري حول توفير
حمايه شرطيه له خلال زيارته المملكه
المتحده حتى في حال سداد تكاليف تلك
الحمايه من ماله الخاص
وقال قاضن في لندن ان الحكومه البريطانيه
لم تتجاوز سلطاتها عندما حرمته من توفير
الحمايه له خلال وجوده في المملكه المتحده
وضحا انه لا ينبغي السماح لضباط الشرطه
بالعمل كحراس شخصيين للاثرياء
نشاط الخامسه من العربيه انتهت اطباء
التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات